foreign
Court
this is not a normal
should there be term limits for the
justice system
President Biden screaming at the sky
over another Supreme Court ruling that
didn't go his way the top Court dealing
a blow to affirmative action after
outlawing the use of race in college
admissions that means Merit matters
again and the media is going to need a
feigning couch
the worst thing about affirmative action
is that it created a Clarence Thomas
Clarence Thomas
you know he has criticized affirmative
action and we know that's one of the
reasons why he's on the Supreme Court I
think uh that this is tantamount to
sticking a dagger in our back we will
begin to see a kind of segregated uh
higher education landscape we're going
to see that segregation become wider and
wider what's next gay marriage is this
leading to no women in colleges soon who
knows
no women in colleges
we can dream I joke and Biden wasn't
done sobbing running over to the safe
space of MSNBC
find it just so out of sports with the
basic value system the American people
do you worry that without Court reform
this conservative majority is too young
and too conservative that they might do
too much harm
well I think they may do too much harm I
think that
some of the Court are beginning to
realize
their legitimacy
is being questioned in ways that hadn't
been questioned in the past he ended
that interview the only way he knows how
by awkwardly shuffling off the set
before they went to commercial there he
goes hey wait a second come back you'll
have something
all right Harold I go to you for no
particular reason at all we haven't seen
you you were on vacation in Europe's
place called Europe must be nice uh the
decision seems to me is based on a
simple idea you can't fight racism with
more racism and I think that's what they
we kind of figured out over over the
last I don't know three four five
decades what say you Mr Ford Jr
so it's good to be back thank you so
much for saying that congrats to the two
of you on the news or at least me thank
you I mean let's face it Jesse's will be
short-lived
oh my God she's already cursing it this
is the great segue to affirmative action
the the uh affirmative action I think
has always been
an imperfect tool to try to address hold
on
try to redress racism
the impact of race and the admissions
process
to promote diversity
um today is an interesting day because
we the way we talk about this sometimes
it's almost like we forget that we
brought affirmative action because we
introduce affirmative action the court
did it was the University of California
medical school decision because race was
a part of all of this now I don't I'm
not as discouraged as some are I look at
some of the numbers you have an absolute
majority of Americans born after 2012
who are minority kids who are people
young people of color 45 of Millennials
are people of color almost 50 percent of
gen Z ears are people of color
in fact the geography and the
demographics and racial composition of
the country has almost surpassed the
Jewish Prudence of the courts now what I
was most encouraged by and I hope that
those who are very critical of this
decision and I'm sorry it's something
about the road I ate potato chips before
coming on
for those who are discouraged
read the entire opinion if you read what
Robert said he said that
an apple universities can still consider
an applicant's discussion of how race
affected his or her life be it through
discrimination or inspiration
family income zip codes all of these
things will continue to be a part of how
we look at this
race alone may not be the way we should
look at this going forward income how
you were raised where you were raised
the kind of experiences you had I still
hope universities are able to and
colleges are able to do that because I
do think one thing that those who have
been very critical of this decision are
right about if we don't find ways to
continue to promote diversity and expand
opportunity you're going to see fewer
doctors fewer lawyers fewer television
producers fewer Arthurs fewer
professionals who might be
African-American Or Hispanic and that's
what I hope we try to achieve and again
the politics will be the politics and
people can say what they want to say
about the court and I have my own
feelings about it
um but I but I hope today is just a new
beginning and I hope that we try to
reimagine and be more creative about how
we promote diversity and how we try to
advance opportunity for every American
you know Dana Harold Ford Jr makes some
good points that at times change and I
think that if you're a minority who gets
a good education and and stays out of
trouble just like anybody else they
actually have more opportunities than
they've ever had before and to deny that
is to deny your own achievements and and
I I saw this dissenting opinion where
Justice Brown Jackson said that
the elephant in the room is race-linked
disparities and they impede achievement
and it's like at a certain point that
almost sounds racist so I like reading
John Robert's opinion and then reading
both Clarence Thomas and katanji brown
Jackson because there you have two
African-American people who are on the
court and they have strong disagreements
about this Thomas writes racialism
simply can't be undone by different or
more racialism we haven't mentioned yet
it was Asian American students who
brought this case yeah because they felt
they were being discriminated against
they weren't asking for specific numbers
to be allowed in they were asking for
fairness when a lot of things well so
many things have changed Sandra Day
O'Connor in 2003 when she was a Justice
she said in 25 years I imagine this is
probably not going to be necessary
anymore well where are we now it's 2023
and in 2005 when I was a spokesperson
for justice Roberts in his confirmation
hearings this issue came up and he has
been working on this for a long time and
it took this case by these Asian
American students to work its way up to
a majority conservative Court in order
to get to this result yeah I wonder if
people who are critical of this decision
can think about the principle that
they're against what is the
constitutional principle you were
against here that's what the Supreme
Court is supposed to do now a lot of the
schools have already figured out and
they're documenting it on Tick Tock and
other places about how they're going to
circumvent what they've expected in this
ruling so there will probably be
questions about that the last thing I
would say about opportunity for people
going to colleges the best thing that we
could possibly do is improve K-12
education amen yeah because then you
will actually be able to have people who
are Reading Writing and doing math and
science and history at grade level and
then maybe you'll choose not to go to
college because there's lots of
different opportunities college is not
the Savior it's it's what happens before
I would love to see some kids
and maybe in poverty impoverished
situation someone take up their case
bring a class action lawsuit like this
one about K-12 education so that we can
improve that so that everybody has a
more equal chance to go to college
excellent point you know Jesse according
to 23andMe I think you were under one
percent African-American and we assume
that's why you got the APM gig and I
didn't
um and yet you see this as a positive
Supreme Court decision while you have
exploited the benefits of it
explain your hypocrisy
well
minorities like me should acknowledge
and I'm just kidding but I do think we
should acknowledge that a lot of
minorities in this country are
heartbroken by this case
and they would acknowledge that they
have achieved Success Through
affirmative action and that they
wouldn't have had opportunities had
affirmative action not have been there
they will acknowledge that so the fact
that that's going away is a big blow to
them so I think we should acknowledge
that but what we should acknowledge is
if this goes away
all the court is saying is that this is
a legal matter that's
constitutional if if Society wants to
change the academic success of African
Americans if African-Americans want to
boost their academic success through
certain emphasis on certain things
there's no one stopping that and there's
no one stopping white Americans Hispanic
Americans all Americans for improving
their own lives it's just that the court
has said this is not our job we will not
endorse discrimination it's against the
14th Amendment
you can't fight discrimination with
discrimination and Clarence Thomas said
race does not determine your value he
said it does not determine success there
are so many other things that go into
success and people have to realize where
we are in life is the result of all the
decisions we've made some of us start on
third base there are certain white
Americans who are getting into these
Elite universities because their fathers
Legacy legacy admissions Athletics
scholarships there are people that do
achieve that but when you argue that
Legacy should go away too if affirmative
action goes away why not legacy it
depends if Jesse's going to Trinity
[Applause]
I knew he was going to say that but you
should look at class but you should look
at class I agree because it's more
socioeconomic than anything there's so
many poor white Americans that are not
opportunities just as the way black
Americans are because they just doesn't
they don't have the income they don't
have the access to to Elite schools in
order to spring from a private boarding
school into Harvard and you have to
accept that but the Supreme Court is not
getting involved in it but going back it
starts before that I think that's why
this is almost in the home yeah but it
starts in grade school
um the judge Nancy Pelosi said this is
why we need term limits and this is from
a person who won't leave Congress unless
she's in a hearse yeah and uh who
doesn't want uh Feinstein to leave
either yes you know this decision will
be the Dobbs decision of 2023. the
Democrats are going to use this the way
they use Dobbs in 2022. it's very simple
affirmative action admission policies
violate the equal protection Clause of
the United States Constitution the 14th
Amendment the 14th amendment was drafted
in the wake of the Civil War uh when
Congress said no one should be denied
the equal protection of the law so if
you follow the Genesis of where this
started and then you go to Plessy and
then you go to Brown versus Board of
education and those famous Supreme Court
cases the court has consistently tried
to make it a Level Playing Field so the
color does not add or take away from the
ability to get a good education and as
Sandra Day O'Connor said you know she
assumed at some point it was going to go
away when is it time for this to go away
it's time for this to go away when we
live in a society now that is so focused
on not just equal opportunity but equal
uh results and I think that this
decision is in itself races because it
says that blacks need a hand up it says
blacks you know you are you're not as
bright so we got to tick that color
thing to get you in what it also says in
terms of today's world is that people
like Randy Weingarten should really not
be promoted the way the woman has been
promoted but she should be her feet
should be held to the fire for what is
happening to kids in our schools because
of the unions kids need to be geared and
schooled in a way where they're at least
able to read and write when they
graduate and that's not the case half a
third graders in this country cannot
read they cannot read so you know the
focus at this point given that this is
the law this is the way it's supposed to
be we've got to make sure that the
elementary school middle school high
schools really focus on making sure kids
got a good education parents have choice
and it's not just the wealthy parents
who can afford to move to get to a
better school but all parents should be
able to get a school to get their
children in school where they can
achieve the results so we'll get them
into these colleges and finally my final
point is I don't want someone who got
into law school or medical school
because of the color of their skin I
don't want someone who's flying a plane
want the best person to operate great on
me the best person to represent me and
the best person to fly me wherever the
hell I'm going I'm done with affirmative
action all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else